[Musica]
grazie grazie di essere 4 altro un posto
bellissimo io non lo conoscevo e visto
da qua a parte le luci è ancora più
bello
mi sono dimenticata il pointer quindi
esco dal punto rosso ma volevo dirvi che
io per l'occasione mi sono messa un
vestito molto particolare perché non so
se sapete la leggenda dai tempi di coco
chanel in poi ogni donna adulta deve
avere un vestito nero investiti in un
tubino no io ho preso questo qui
soprattutto per raccontarvi come mai
questo è finito nel mio guardaroba è una
storia abbastanza strana ed è questo
questo vestito apparteneva a una
prendetela così un attrice americana non
posso dire il nome
questa attrice americana ha fatto la sua
tournée in italia era stata a milano
venezia a roma e poi si era presa
qualche giorno di vacanza qui in toscana
ed era finita in un agriturismo nel
paese dopo i miei nonni hanno la casa di
famiglia quindi insomma dove anch'io con
i miei cugini sono abituata ad andare
quando così un fine settimana d'estate
lei cosa ha fatto lei è stata i suoi
giorni nell'agriturismo ha mandato il
vestito a lavare quindi ha incaricato
l'assistenza e la settante personale di
andare lavanderia e lavanderia è stato
lavato il vestito è rimasto lì
lavanderia e nessuno è più andato a
ritirarlo quindi l'attrice americana è
ripartita per l'america e questo vestito
è rimasto qui in un paese qui nelle
vicinanze poi un giorno la signora della
lavanderia si è resa conto che questo
vestito le era rimasto accollato il
nipote le ha detto sì a metterlo su ebay
ma lei insomma un po ci teneva un giorno
e ho visto passare e mi ha inseguito per
strada con silvia segnò una cosa da
farti vedere magari magari ti piace
anche e sono andata nel retrobottega mi
ha dato questo vestito
io me lo sono messo e calzava a pennello
sembrava fatto apposta per me
e allora la signora della lavanderia ha
detto beh da adesso è tua
perché vi ho raccontato questa storia ve
l'ho raccontata perché falsa perché non
è affatto vero non è andata affatto così
la storia però non è del tutto falsa
ci tengo a dire ci sono delle parti vere
delle parti verosimili delle parti
plausibili delle parti che voi potreste
verificare adesso per esempio se la mia
famiglia ha una casa di proprietà qui
nei paraggi è plausibile sentite il mio
100 parlo toscano quindi potrebbe non
essere sbagliato invece falso e ci sono
delle parti inverosimili ma abbastanza
avere per esempio che questo vestito
io lo abbia avuto dopo un passaggio di
qualcuno di famoso dall italia è
abbastanza vero però io lavoro in zona
rai e capita anche che le cose possono
essere andate in maniera molto più
semplice di così velo anche raccontata
perché io ormai di mestiere vengo
chiamata e appunto anche qui c'è stato
c'è stata un pò questa questa questa
chiamata a raccontare bufale fake news
cosa c'è di falso nelle cose che che i
giornalisti soprattutto quando hanno a
che fare con la scienza ci raccontano
però ho pensato che forse poteva essere
più interessante raccontare il contrario
cioè raccontarvi quanto invece la verità
possa non essere così vera e quanto sia
difficile parlare di verità insomma le
bufale lasciamo stare quelle diciamo le
diamo per assodato e se una cosa è una
balla è una balla però anche le verità
possono assumere aspetti molto diversi
possono adattarsi per esempio voi
potreste pensare l'unica cosa vera che
questo vestito è nero anche questo per
la scienza può essere opinabile siete
voi sono i vostri occhi che lo vedono
così perché non riflette la luce e
abbiamo un fisiologo poi questa cosa ce
la potrà spiegare spiegare meglio però
in generale si può dire che il problema
originario è la scienza cioè io che devo
scrivere di scienza quando a che fare
con la verità della scienza devo capire
che cosa si intende in quell'ambito lì
per verità la scienza parla di leggi di
natura ma le leggi di natura non
esistono nella natura sono il nostro
modo di leggere le cose che ci succedono
di intorno e di conseguenza sono anche
valide finché noi della natura abbiamo
una certa visione poi vengono superate
infatti gli scienziati ci tengono
che sono provvisorie no quindi
provvisorie e magari circoscritte cioè
se adesso io faccio cadere il puntatore
il puntatore casca a terra e va
benissimo newton per riscrivere questo
singolare fenomeno ma se invece voglio
andare su marte ho bisogno di conoscere
la fisica del novecento
allo stesso modo la scienza vi dirà
licenziate mi diranno quelli più onesti
che la scienza utilizza parole e numeri
e formule che sono convenzioni
esattamente come nel nostro linguaggio
quindi già la parola verità nella
scienza è già un oggetto abbastanza
abbastanza delicato poi ci sono tante
situazioni in cui a noi conviene un po
questa verità adattarlo alla nostra vita
io ne farò vedere quattro sono
situazioni in cui l'adattamento è chiaro
e riconoscibile e anche diciamo onesto
le altre sono situazioni in cui se ne
potrebbe a lungo discutere io ne faccio
vedere quattro se ne potrebbero essere
migliaia
una è la questione della terra chi dice
oggi che la terra è piatta lo mettiamo
nella nel lato bufale però se io da qui
devo andare a piazza del campo voi mi
fate una marchetta su un foglio di carta
è considerata la terra piatta
modellizzata la terra come se fosse
piatta e va benissimo a me che devo
andare soltanto fino a piazza del campo
e non su marte e va benissimo a voi
quindi questa verità alla stiamo
adattando la comodità della nostra vita
poi ci sono circostanze un pochino più
complicate in cui ad adattare la verità
è quello che noi vogliamo che la verità
ci dica quindi per esempio questo
signore qua lo conoscete tutti quanti e
darwin
lui ha descritto delle leggi di natura
che volevano in biologia questo signore
qua herbert spencer che ha preso
praticamente sono coevi le
le leggi di natura descritte da darvi
nella adattata alla descrizione della
società quindi ha cominciato a dire cosa
refrein che si sente dire abbastanza
spesso tutt'oggi che nel mondo
sopravvive chi si adatta meglio ai
cambiamenti questo descrivendo una
società abbastanza spietata che lascia
indietro chi non ce la fa e il
darwinismo sociale che diciamo uno
stiracchiamento che darmi non avrebbe
mai concesso perché vi rendete conto che
molto classista anche no
e oggi però dagli ne sono discese
diciamo teorie sociali abbastanza
controversa non tuttora molto presente
nelle nostre vite
terzo sistema per cui la verità
scientifica noi ogni tanto la dobbiamo
rivedere quanto riguarda molto da vicino
le nostre vite e soprattutto la nostra
salute allora lì e per quanto la verità
scientifica la scienza ci dica delle
cose noi queste cose le dobbiamo
adattare ad altri sistemi di valori le
dobbiamo discutere dobbiamo farci delle
leggi non possiamo pensare che siccome
in biologia le cose stanno così allora
la legge italiana debba assolutamente
comportarsi di conseguenza perché tra di
noi esistono sistemi valoriali
rispettabilissimi come quelli della
religione
qualcuno non c'era qualcuno ce l'ha
bisogna mettersi d'accordo
e questa cosa riguarda più che la
scienza in sé riguarda il tipo di
società che noi vogliamo costruire con
l'aiuto tra le altre cose della scienza
quarto caso riguarda la scienza di per
sé la scienza di per sé gli scienziati
tendono a descriverla come un mondo
assai puro dove si perseguono degli
scopi sociali che sono benefici per
tutta l'umanità e gli scienziati
lavorano insieme per arrivare a degli
obiettivi comuni beh in realtà non è
così la scienza ha bisogno di soldi
la scienza si fa per cooperazioni la
scienza ha bisogno di politica di nuovo
bisogna decidere insieme che tipo di
società del che tipo di futuro vogliamo
avere davanti insomma bisogna decidere
se i soldi dei contribuenti europei li
mettiamo sul infrarosso o sul carbonio
per dirne una
sulla robotica o sulle neuroscienze sono
tanti soldi dobbiamo costruire insieme
questo tipo
di dibattito e sono scelte di fatto
politiche non c'è un'oggettività dentro
questi queste scelte
tutto questo io ve lo riassunto così ma
ovviamente ci sono diversi secoli di
filosofia diversi secoli di sistemo
logie io di mestiere racconto la scienza
e allora adesso faccio un passo avanti
faccio vedere quattro modi con i quali
noi che raccontiamo la scienza possiamo
diciamo distorcere ancora di più questa
verità
1 non dipende soltanto da noi questo ce
l'ho messo perché si parla sempre male
dei giornalisti vi vorrei far vedere che
ogni tanto se sbagliamo e perché la
verità c'è un po fregati questo era il
si parla di inflazione cosmica questi
sono i siti istituzionali delle agenzie
che si occupano di questo tipo di
ricerca insomma onde gravitazionali 2014
onde gravitazionali ne scriviamo tutti
quanti eppure un anno dopo ufficiali
that
beh insomma si erano sbagliati loro non
c'eravamo sbagliati noi erano era della
polvere che insomma un po confuso e gli
strumenti succede
la scienza va avanti così accettabile
anzi è quasi bello nel sistema scienza
ogni tanto fare gli errori e correggerli
con il conforto dell'intera comunità
andare avanti febbraio 2016 le onde
gravitazionali sono state viste davvero
secondo sistema può succedere quello che
succede in biologia alla fisica è molto
più semplice in fisica sono tutti quanti
sempre d'accordo in biologia nella
ricerca biomedica ci possono essere cose
di questo tipo come quelle che
riguardano l'editing genetico notizie
che solo 20 giorni dopo vengono un po
nel nostro gergo si dice ridimensionate
beh non è che abbiamo proprio corretto
gli errori genetici degli embrioni umani
l'abbiamo detta così un mese dopo tutti
insieme non ridimensioniamo terzo caso
il terzo caso e quando ci arriva una
verità abbiamo capito licenziate hanno
capito che la carne rossa può essere
cancerogena ma è troppo complicato star
a spiegare come quando e perché noi
abbiamo due righe e mezzo per fare un
titolo ed ecco questo titolo qui non è
falso è vero che la carne rossa e
cancerogena però non è vero che lui è
quanto il fumo è l'amianto ed è
è una cosa abbastanza sottile che
purtroppo è passata così qui non è colpa
di nessuno però la verità è arrivata in
una maniera un po diversa da quella che
avrebbe dovuto essere il suo percorso
quarto sistema è chiaramente la truffa
anche questo lo dovremmo mettere
nell'ambito delle bufale c'è chi un po
le distingue vi faccio vedere questo
caso soltanto perché qui hanno truffato
sia gli scienziati sia i giornalisti
quindi non non c'è nessun colpevole
questo è un giornale francese che
pubblica la notizia che finalmente si
sono trovate le prove della
cancerogenicità degli ogm
ho tanti decenni che si cercava di dire
che gli ogm causano il cancro non ci si
era riusciti
ed ecco qui bene qui sia il giornalista
sia lo scienziato avevano fatto diciamo
degli errori consapevoli che avevano i
casi molto gravi gli scienziati avevano
truccato le ricerche giornalisti non
l'avevano verificata sarebbero due
errori molto grossi se vogliamo
chiamarle errori in realtà in realtà è
qualcosa di peggio quindi abbiamo visto
che la verità scientifica in se ha dei
problemi
la scienza in sé è una costruzione un
pochino più complessa di un oggetto in
grado di darci 10 vero falso
il racconto della scienza a sua volta la
modifica c'è un terzo elemento che
peggiora le cose
ed è come voi la capite ti ho detto il
vestito in nero forse non è così i
vostri occhi lo vedono come nero ma poi
c'è un altro attore che il vostro
cervello che interpreta quella roba lì
come nero il vostro cervello è come il
mio come quello degli scienziati non è
un sistema perfetto se gli raccontato
una fiaba io avrete capito che ho citato
cenerentola nel mettermi il vestito che
mi calzava a pennello voi in questa
fiaba cercate buoni cercate cattivi
cercate un eroe che sconfigge il cattivo
e se così non è voi più o meno così
capite poi comunque la fate facile per
voi le carni rosse causano il cancro per
voi come per noi insomma è il fatto che
la ricezione non sia sempre perfetta è
il terzo attore che complica le cose in
tutto questo insomma voglio dirvi che il
nostro cervello è fatto apposta dall
evoluzione per mille ragioni
per credere alle cose un po raffazzonata
e talvolta anche proprio alle false
bufale
quanto alla scienza e al suo racconto
non chiedeteci la verità non ve lo
possiamo dare noi che raccontiamo la
scienza non riusciremo mai a darvi la
verità
vedremo però il racconto di qualcosa di
migliore qualcosa di umano e secondo me
anche terribilmente affascinante grazie
spero che mi sia piaciuto il mio vestito
[Applauso]
[Musica]